[Music]
so it is time for the press preview
first look at what is on the front pages
and tonight we'll check out the
headlines with the editor of the jewish
chronicle jake wallace simons and the
white hall editor at the financial times
at sebastian payne evening to you both
we'll chat in a moment first of all
let's check out those front pages
starting with the ft putin puts nuclear
forces on alert reads the front of the
financial times as they look at the
west's imposed sanctions against
russia's central bank the times carries
this same headline
vlad nukes on standby is the headline
for the metro which also highlights the
proposed peace talks between russian and
ukrainian leaders
the daily telegraph runs with the same
story their headline putin issues
nuclear threat
mad vlad goes nuclear says the sun
the star also has a picture of vladimir
putin on the front with the headline
madder than a box of frogs
the guardian says the backlash against
president putin is growing with a
picture of an enormous anti-war protest
that one taking place in berlin
dash to the borders is the headline for
the eyes ukrainians flee their country
more than three hundred thousand are
believed to have left and the mirror
also has the same story and pictures
a father and a son saying a tearful
goodbye at a train station
and let me remind you of course by
scanning the qr code you'll see on
screen join the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
uh while you watch and listen to us and
i'm joined tonight by jake wally simons
and sebastian payne sebastian why don't
we start with you and uh terrifying
headlines really aren't they uh the sun
uh going all out with mad vlad goes
nuclear putin raising the specter of
nuclear attack he says he's putting his
nuclear deterrent forces on high alert i
mean some confusion about what that
actually means
well i think what it means in a very
simple sense is that the tensions have
been heightened significantly over this
war in europe that the fact is that you
know um this has not gone to plan for
president vladimir putin of russia that
and the whole calculation as we've heard
from western ministers was a quick sharp
war where russia would invade ukraine
and it would take care of the capital
install a puppet government and it would
all be over in a matter of days or even
weeks and it really has not gone like
that whatsoever instead it's been a much
more drawn out conflict kiev is still in
control of um the zelinski government
and the the fighting back from ukrainian
forces has been incredible and there's
been some absolutely astounding footage
on social media showing despite the fact
that being outclassed in power and
manpower they really are pushing back
and so this decision by vladimir putin
to raise russia's nuclear and weapons to
the highest level is obviously very
worrying for everyone involved here and
there's quite a lot of mixed
interpretations about what this means
that some of the papers tomorrow say
this is actually a distraction to try
and get away from the fact that russia
is not winning this conflict it's not
going to plan and it's not actually
going to radically change everything
others including the times tomorrow
saying this is symbolic of his state of
mind lots of people think that vladimir
putin i think it's the style that says
madder than a box of frogs but in the
defense secretary ben wallace has also
suggested that maybe his thought process
on this whole crisis is not what it
should be but either way it shows the
tensions are rising it's not going to
plan for russia and i think as
everybody's just said people need to
keep a calm head at this moment and
we've seen the first indications of some
talks between um ukraine and russia
they've not gone anywhere at the moment
but obviously that would be the best
outcome to this whole messy awful
situation yeah it's been a strange day
on the one hand uh you know the threat
of nuclear attack but on the other hand
both sides agreeing to talk jake let's
look at the front of the guardian putin
puts nuclear force on harlot as backlash
grows that huge demonstration uh in
berlin
what are your thoughts is this nuclear
threat in order to divert attention
because he has miscalculated this
invasion
well i think in a normal in normal times
one would say that a country like russia
would make a nuclear threat really as a
bluff but if you rewind a couple of
weeks everyone thought that putin was
bluffing when he put more than 100 000
troops on the border of ukraine nobody
really thought that he was going to take
the step of invading and so i think that
that makes adds a sense of jeopardy to
these uh nuclear threats or the idea of
him putting nuclear forces on on high
alert i think it's important to drill
down to what's actually going on here
putin is referring to a 2020
announcement by russia a new policy
announcement which was that it would
reserve the right to use nuclear weapons
in retaliation when facing an
existential threat from conventional
weapons uh from an aggressor uh whether
that's the west or nato whether that's
ukraine or another country
and you know it's it's not clear whether
that means the the use of tactical
nuclear weapons which is nuclear weapons
on a small scale in warfare which we've
never seen before in history or
something bigger so there's a sort of
intentional vagary here that's been used
strategically by putin to try to instill
fear into the ukrainians and into uh you
know nato and the west at large um but
it seems like at the moment what is
really evoking is a stronger backlash by
the ukraine and indeed by western powers
as well
yeah and sebastian just going back to
your paper the financial times clearly
putin has been rattled by uh the
sanctions hasn't he and i see that uh
the front of the ft talking about uh bp
unloading nearly 20 percent of its stake
in in rosneft
indeed just before i come on to the bp
story i think it's just worth noting as
well that obviously the
the when russia's financial markets open
on monday it could well be that its
whole economy will spiral into free fall
because we've now got global agreement
to cut russia off from the swift banking
system that's used for international
payments there was some dispute between
european nations about that last week
and they found unity on that plus
there's also been moves by several
central banks across the world to um
free the assets of russia's central
banks so economically that pain is
really going to hit tomorrow and this is
symbolized by that story you mentioned
on the front of the ft that bp is
selling off its 20
and rosneft the russian oil and fund and
that is 25 billion dollars it you cannot
underestimate what a huge transaction
that is it's been held since 2013 we
also know that bernard looney who's
chief executive of bp is leaving the
board of rosnef with the media effect
and another director as well so what
you've seen over this weekend is first
of all almost total solidarity from the
west which i think vladimir putin did
not expect the ratcheting up of
sanctions which is continuing an expert
will go on in the coming days and weeks
as well uh and you can understand why
it's created the cut that kind of uh
threat on the nuclear weapons fund
because in the information war in the
unity war in the actual war russia is
losing across the whole border this
which is not what it expected and i
think that bp announcement will be
reflected by many other companies you
know we know that uefa has ended the
champions league he's not going to be
held in saint petersburg and i think all
big western institutions are going to
start pulling out and away from russia
very rapidly while this thing continues
now again we'll create much more
domestic pressure at home for vladimir
putin and we've seen some amazing um
pictures and footage this weekend of the
protest in petersburg which again and
moscow it's a very difficult and
delicate thing to do in russia but it's
it's clear above the board that this is
not what putin had hoped for and you
just have to wonder at this stage what's
the out of it like how does this thing
come to a conclusion yeah um he is
looking uh increasingly isolated isn't
he thank you both for the moment coming
up the exodus from ukraine as people
head to neighbouring countries for
safety
[Music]
you